welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka death Vader and
it's time to go back to a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away with the
release of the sixth episode of the
mandalorian throughout this video we'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the latest episodes
overall plot the Easter eggs and our
theories of what could be happening in
the future this episode kind of feels
like a sidequest
but it fills in a lot of the titular
characters backstory rather than
progressing the plot so there's still a
lot to unpack from it there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch episode 6 yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns like this every day
and without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Mandalorian episode six
okay so episode six titled the prisoner
it pretty much centers around man our
doing a jailbreak with a group of
mercenaries and bounty hunters this
episode has an awesome cast in it that's
made up of actors like Bill burr Clancy
Brown Richard I O'Day mark Boone jr. and
Natalie tenner who plays a twi'lek known
as Sheehan that has a history with mando
it's heavily hinted that the two had a
romantic relationship with one another
and that leaves the question did he take
the helmet off or did he wrap it or
never mind
maybe he's a Gungan under there I really
don't know there's some flurry back and
forth banter between the two and yeah
it's good to know that mando at least
doesn't spend all of his time with
babies we kind of get the feeling that
family came in the way between them on a
big job and this pays off with one of
the big reveals in the episode now if
you've been keeping up to date with the
breakdowns on the channel so far then
you'll know that we've theorized that
mando will build a network in order to
take down the empire members that are
after him and I'll give them a theories
on how this expands on that at the end
of the video we learn from the others in
the episode that mando has a dark past
and may have even been involved in the
mass murder of people though this isn't
said for definite and at the moment it's
all just speculation the group itself is
led by Ron played by Boone jr. and it
includes Mayfield Berg who is a Deveraux
nyan zero a droid and the previously
mentioned Cheyenne I just thought I'd
mention there
as they'll be referring to them
throughout the video so yeah it is
important to know their names similar to
last week baby Yoda takes a back seat
once more which is a shame as I feel
like the baby is really the main thrust
of the season and wrapping up its
storyline is pretty much everything that
we're here for anyway the episode opens
with mono going on a galactic Cruiser in
search of work as we know from the last
episode that the guy is extremely short
of money money buys fuel levers for baby
Yoda and so on so yeah he needs it since
being exiled from the guild he's had to
reach out to more nefarious contacts and
this opening is as atmospheric as always
making the introduction feel enthralling
ran apparently once man up for the job
because he wants to use the races crest
as with it being an ex-military craft
from the days before the Empire it's not
wired up with the same surveillance that
most cruisers have since the fall of the
Republic so yeah it's a hunk of junk
that looks like a Kanto bite slot
machine shoutouts the last Jedi but it's
perfect for the job there is some
ulterior motives behind the jailbreak as
revealed later and I'll discuss these as
they happen in the recap quickly though
we learn this isn't your regular Prison
Break and we learned that the person
that they want to bust out is actually
located on a maximum-security New
Republic prisoner craft from the episode
with Korra Jun we did learn that since
the fall of the Empire the New Republic
ended up getting too heavily bogged down
in politics which caused her to take an
early retirement and this situation is
exemplified here the New Republic's lack
of authority in the galaxy is pretty
much what caused the first order to rise
and we can see that they definitely
aren't all that cut out to be
anyway the ship is run completely by
droids which does make things easier but
it also shows that the New Republic
didn't really have a grasp on how to
properly run the galaxy in the wake of
the Empire's destruction I mean yeah
don't use droids to do everything we all
saw what happened to the Trade
Federation this episode shows that
droids they'll build to be faster more
intelligent and better all-round
or actually not all they're cracked up
to be and yeah the New Republic's
reliance on them was probably their
downfall
you also get lip service paid to the
fact that the Mandalorians are all but
extinct and whilst I don't think this is
completely true I do think that the
numbers are very low
it does look like after the events of
Episode three that the group were at
least highly scattered after that battle
on Navarro and news of their death is
troubled for we also learned that
mayfield was an imperial sharpshooter
which man no quips at and says that's
not saying too much mayfield replies i
wasn't a stormtrooper wiseass and this
is kind of an in-joke in the Star Wars
community about how stormtroopers are
all terrible shots and yeah it's nice to
see the show giving a little nod to fans
with this line he has two guns that look
extremely like Jango Fett Shu blasters
and whilst all the Easter eggs are nice
it kind of sucks to have baby Yoda not
really in the plot that much
however baby owners not out for too long
and he comes up quickly on the ship when
during the fight between Berg and mondo
they accidentally open a locker with the
character in none of the crew really
know what species it is which yeah we
still don't know either as George Lucas
has never really divulged their name and
it cements just how rare the creature is
not only for the characters in the show
but also the audience as well is he a
baby is he this year's must-have
Christmas toy you're damn right like
everyone else though they clearly gained
a love for the little guy and even pick
him up though you probably want to put
them back because yeah baby oda has been
dropped on its head way too many times
lately and this again happens in the
episode they arrive at the new republic
vessel which has a doorway that is very
similar to the one we see on the Falcon
and Empire and this cements that this is
our airlocks function in the Star Wars
universe on the ship which is very
similar internally to the blockade
runner from a new hope mainly due to its
all-white interior we do see that
several prisoners are there including an
adrenaline you might remember the
adrenaline from the solo solo movie that
was voiced by Jon Favreau and yeah it's
nice to just see one of the other
species members pop appear the group go
through the corridors running into a
mouse droid and come face to face with
droid soldiers who are pretty useless
when it comes to mando I love this
action scene and yet seeing him take
down the machines is an amazing moment
that really hammers home just how
skilled he is eventually they make their
way to the control room where they run
into a New Republic officer and this is
a nice little Easter Egg as
character is played by Matt Lanter who
actually voiced Anakin in the Clone Wars
TV show man Oh doesn't want to kill him
but after he threatens to sound the
alarm on a tracking beacon they're left
with very little choice xi'an takes him
out but he still sends out the SOS
device and this sets a time limit of 20
minutes for the job the group run
through the corridors taking down droids
and fighting their way to the prisoner
who it's revealed is Quinn
Cheyenne's brother who we learn is in
jail because of mando this is the real
reason that he was selected for the job
as they wanted to use his skillset to
set free Cheyenne's brother steal his
ship and then trap him in the jail nice
plan and all but yeah you guys clearly
weren't counting on how resourceful
mando is and he escapes the cell heads
to the control room and puts the whole
craft in lockdown
it's an awesome moment in which the hunt
has become the hunted and I got flashes
of Rambo where he takes down the
officers mando is like the predator
moving through the Cara using all of the
weapons at his disposal including the
whistling birds flamethrowers and more
one by one he takes them down before
finally making its way to Quinn zero
also tries to kill baby Yoda but I guess
all of the audience channel their energy
into the little guy because he manages
to evade the drought for quite a while I
love the juxtaposition of the scenes
with the crew trying to outrun mando
whilst on board the ship a baby Yoda
tries to outrun zero it's really tense
especially because we know in the
background that the New Republic forces
are slowly coming for them all mando
tries the door trick once more from the
first episode on berg and this fails and
he has to kind of double down on this
which eventually knocks the character
out there's no love lost with Shayan
either and he brutally takes her out to
moving to Mayfield to sneak up on the
character in a very Batman Eska moment
finally mando reaches Quinn who begs for
his life and there's a long wait here to
find out what really happened
I love the tension here at this point as
we do learn that mando has a dark past
of murder and he's kind of been pushed
to the edge here however he does stick
to the code saves baby Yoda from zero
and returns to ran in order to get the
money I do kind of wish we got to see
baby Oda defeat zero but hey I guess not
ran follows his policies of no questions
asked and he doesn't inquire too much
about the missing crew however as soon
mando leaves ran orders to have the
races crest taken out and we watch is
what looks like a sis bomber arrived in
the hangar
unfortunately for him Quinn discovers
that mando has placed the New Republic
tracker on him and x-wings
arrived to the hub to destroy it I loved
seeing the cavalry come in and yet just
hearing the inside of x-wing cockpits is
awesome
at least the wreck for you to all of the
pilots and the x-wings our previous
directors of the Mandalorian so this is
a nice little moment for them the
episode ends back on the prison vessel
with the group all locked up letting us
know that mando let them live now have
been saying that manner will be building
a network and I think this ending kind
of solidifies that as there's no real
reason to leave the characters alive for
them to not come back though we still
don't know who the mysterious character
at the end of last week's episode was I
do think that it was Mothe Gideon and
not Bubba Fett and as we know the moth
is going to be in this season so with
just two episodes left I can see him
being brought into it I know the Bubba
Fett sound effects are the same and so
on but yeah Star Wars always reusing
sound effects for being just look at the
Wilhelm scream and I'm doubling down on
my theory that it's Mothe Gideon he has
to show up at some point and I really
hope that next week he does as we have
to get back to the main story as there's
there's only so long you can do side
quests for though I did have fun with
the Sentry I think now is the time to
return to the real me of the story and
let's force pray that this carries on
next week now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the Mandalorian Episode
six as well as what your theories for
the future are make sure you leave them
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the series so far which
would be linked at the end we go over
every episode breaking it down bit by
bit so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more also if
you're interested in the rise of
Skywalker we just dropped a full movie
breakdown of the film so if you want to
know the plot ahead of time then make
sure you head over to that if you want
to come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 2 boxer and blu-ray which
can
Black Panther infinity war endgame
Captain Marvel amour and all you had to
do to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video which she subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the mandalorian in the comment section
below the one is gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of December and this
set will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprise it's the best of luck
that everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace